before i start i want to let you guys
know inshallah i am trying to raise five
hundred thousand meals for muslim aid
please please guys go to the link and
give these people are starving imagine
you help them have iftar and sisters
imagine the reward that you will get do
check that out in the link in the
description box below inshallah we're
going to get straight into this video
there's a new brand on the scene called
alif they make 100 halal raw cat food
there are countless health benefits to
this new raw diet check them out on
instagram at alif dot uk they do monthly
subscription boxes and you can get ten
percent discount on their two-week trial
box with my code ali10 check them out
now and let your cat enjoy some nice
food assalamu alaikum what happened
to brothers and sisters and dear friends
welcome once again to my channel
allah talks about them in the quran and
they are mentioned specifically in a
hadith brothers and sisters now one
thing that a lot of people make a
mistake which i've seen you know people
of knowledge
is that they try to comprehend and
understand how is who is yahuja where
are they how could they stay in a cave
for so long and did they dig and just
when they're about to come out and
obviously there's it should some say
there's issues with that narration etc
some
parts of it you know are not authentic
whatever it may be i'm not trying to get
into that okay you know and then um
and you know there's so many
speculations etc and a lot of people
come
and they're like some people even get
into doubt with this matter some
individuals even leave islam and i'm
like what's the issue here let me tell
you guys the crux of the matter because
there are a lot of people and love
individuals who have tried to make
people understand this and even push the
narrative of these certain ex-muslims
you know that you know people um are
leaving islam because of this apparently
yeah which i just said one individual
and most of his reasons were because you
know he couldn't have intimacy with a
lot of girls or something along those
lines okay i don't think it was this
issue at all yeah it was more of his
desires the point is this that we fall
for this and then what we try to do is
in return is like i know let's try to
bring it down to a logical level and try
to explain it in a logical way now i've
seen many people do these videos okay
many people one of those were was uh dr
yasser khadi you know the thing is now
it's ramadan i'm not here to talk about
anybody
etc okay i don't want to make anything
to ruin my fast my ramadan et cetera all
i'm just saying is obviously there's a
lot of things i don't agree with dr
sakadi and there's things i agree with
also so the thing is here it's just i
don't want to get into the details of
the integrity the point i'm trying to
make is he also done a video on this
matter the point i'm trying to say and
what i don't understand is this why do
we have to understand everything in the
context where why does it always have to
be logical why does it have to be
something where we're like oh explain it
to me logically or you know i'm going to
start doubting things this is exactly
why shaitaan fell into this belief when
allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala told him to do
something bow down to adam he couldn't
comprehend logically why he had to do
that when he feels like he's better than
him
the problem is this
taking the uncle over the knuckle that
is exactly our problem and we apply this
into our day-to-day life i have to
understand this logically
who do you think you are i mean how
arrogant you must be to say i need to
know everything subhanallah who do you
think you are
either you're going to be like iblis and
rebel against allah and fed fall into
this belief or number two you're going
to submit allah like adam al-salam and
accept the knuckle the text allah saying
and leave that realm to him you don't
know what allah is talking about how
it's going to happen in what form you
have no clue allah subhanahu wa kind of
works in mysterious ways he's created
the heavens and the earth he is the
owner of everything
how dare you try to bring something
which you might not comprehend or
understand or doesn't make sense to you
now and try to bring it to a human level
and like in a logical way and try to
answer it and like oh this might be
robots and i'm not talking about
specifically i'm talking in general you
know this might be this or this might be
that et cetera no maybe it's none of
that maybe allah is going to show us
may allah protect us i don't want to see
that yeah in a in a way where we're all
going to be like oh my gosh i would have
never thought of that if you told me
think about it for a million billion
years
why is it impossible for allah to enable
them to be hidden somewhere and
eventually they're going to come out and
they're going to be in their billions or
trillions and whatever it may be
i believe in allah i believe in this
messenger i believe in the quran if
allah said if his messenger said that's
what it is
that is what it is
period i don't need to bring it to how
does it happen but it doesn't make sense
to me who cares with your little brain
yeah who are you with your little brain
to try to understand these things there
are some things that we don't know and
we would never know that's the main
reason i'm doing this video because i've
been keeping this in for the past one
and a half year guys come on what enough
is wrong with you guys put your trust in
allah allah
works in ways you will never imagine you
can never comprehend so leave that
matter to him you focus on your ibadah
focus on your salah don't worry about
this stuff your salah your fasting your
zakah your
hajj righteousness to your parents your
wife your spouse helping community at
large and doing what is best for
humanity and you have your trust in
allah and you will find that on the day
of judgement now you can find out two
ways on the day of judgement you can
come and say oh allah i wanted to know
how this whole uh uh yejudjian majus
thing
actually was and allah shows you and
you're like oh my gosh and if i would
have never thought of that
and as a believer you would go to jenna
knowing what you saw yes okay having
pizza ah like ibrahim alaihis allah
subhana wa
so certain things
or you can be standing in front of allah
as a disbeliever who's destined to hell
fire and you ask allah before you enter
hellfire about it i mean the yeji jim
which i doubt you're going to and allah
shows you and you're convinced but guess
what you died as a disbeliever
the choice is yours
i'd rather take allah's text what allah
said over my little brain all day every
day till next time assalamu alaikum
warahmatullahi wabarakatuh